So hydro, everyone, my
name is Pablo Rodriguez.
I am from south of his pain was
currently working on doing maybe to the
Barcelona isn't the Institute of Marine
Sciences which is close to personae
Davita. I don't know if
you have therapy there. Um,
so my research topic for my phd
is mostly focusing bio chemistry.
So bio chemistry, science that involves
biology, geology and chemistry.
So the change,
essentially what we do is to research
what the elements of the periodic table do
on the earth, right? How I trucking
moves in the ecosystem. How Carol,
how sulfur nitrogen to right.
So I'm here at the,
to do in our research this day of a month,
I was last year too,
in order to use computer science to
understand the biological chemical cycles
that are in the ocean because that
what we do focusing the oceans, um,
what we studying is how the oceans,
it speaks to the oceans is speak with the
atmosphere, right? So many of you know,
CO2, which is our gas, which has many
important effects on the atmosphere.
But there are also many gases that we
call trace gases because the concentration
is so is too low that they
have important roles too.
So today's the world oceans day.
And the first thing I like
to ask you is why oceans?
Because actually if we think
the earth is a map, right?
Which the way in which they bought and
part it's not the land if the ocean,
so how many oceans are here?
So essentially as one, right?
But mentally we can divide it in different
oceans and obviously every ocean has
different roles. So if we want to
understand how the ocean works,
the global oceans,
we call it,
we need to understand how it works
in the different parts of it, right?
So it's eventually, it's like a
puzzle that you have one piece.
You know how a process
behaves in this part,
how process behave in this part because
you put everything together and you have
the whole thing.
So when I was had a child,
I really love exploration.
I was born in Cartagena,
which is a city in the south of Spain.
And he's very famous because
it hustled of history.
This is a Roman theater
was, yeah, Roman theater,
one of the oldest one in the world.
Um, this is the boat is there.
If there's various research vessel,
which is the Polaris money special
and the base of the of the vessel is,
is in my home phone.
So since I was a teller,
really loves the exploration and
science and these kinds of things.
So this is the first picture of the, of
the earth. They came for Apollo Eight,
right?
That's the first picture of the year
taking from the space for a human being.
So that's the moon surface and there
is the year there. So as we can see,
the earth is blue. So then blue marble,
I don't know if you have forever Lisa,
these different with this famous
phrase like near blue marble from you,
from people like cars, Saigon. Um,
so, but until we can see clouds,
belts are important, right? So
we can see that these thing blue,
it has wide and also the continent,
which is Africa.
So let's here, if we assume it in the
picture, I mean we will have this,
this, this view of the
years, but this is not true.
I'm actually [inaudible] clouds are
missing away. Clouds are important.
Clouds are white. That's where y'all
views, right? Assaulting these flies,
Eh, it's helps you. For
example, if you are,
if you have to do a sport
in summer academies is you,
you have really high temperatures but
usually need to wear bright to life flows,
right? So 40 years is the
same, but the light art or,
or the bright parts of the earth
help the earth to make in schooler,
right? Called him Sir. And what?
He sees so many thoughts.
We has tally clouds when we are tutoring,
right? Schools, high school, I usually
teach her. Some professor told us, okay,
so in order to have a cloud,
you need the water to the sound light
will hit the water on the ocean or a lake,
whatever.
The water will be evaporated.
We'll go through the atmosphere and
eventually we'll condense. I saw magic,
you will have a cloud,
right?
But the truth is that this
is not that simple, right?
So you need articles,
we did the small particles that are
floating in the atmosphere in which the
water that water molecules [inaudible].
Right?
So these articles can
be from the industry,
can be it cars for example of her,
I mean for all you've done last film,
even they can be viruses,
they're flowing in the atmosphere
and the water can come dance.
So you have these particle,
the water condensing the particle and
after they be called many of them to
winter.
So you have small cloud
droplets and eventually if
you have many small droplets,
you will have a cloud. So it's not that
simple, right? This is the western her,
um, this is Saharan dust, right?
Which is really important for
these processes. So all this does,
it goes from the desert to the ocean
and up in the atmosphere helping these
cloud formation processes.
Right? And also this dust, yes,
for eternal can go from here to
the Amazon rain forest 30 license.
Right? So this is sort of
so important. I usually,
so that's why you okay ms three
B now we're not the atmosphere,
the ocean Dalon on everything is
connected some way somehow. Right?
But these higher fires that also
contributes to them to them.
I Aerosol particle budget in the
atmosphere industry as I said before.
So they got them the amount of energy
that the earth can reflect right from the
song.
We call it the Albedo effect.
So the higher the number in the border,
right?
The better for us because the
temperature will be lower, right?
This is a victory.
We take out all the clouds if
we take him out, all of them.
So we will have the
Albedo from the desert,
which are quite right too
for the polar regions. Um,
the ocean on the elevator from the ocean,
which is something we can say
that this narrative, right?
Because it's really dark.
So we have an Albedo effect factor of
zero point 15 but if we include clouds is
a dabble of it.
So essentially belts are really important.
So I told you that the dust on
the particles in the industry,
they go to the asthma sphere.
Also from the deserts,
but even leading beings like blondes,
they can release their articles, right?
Or gas is that when they are oxidizing
the atmosphere with the react,
we're reacting. We felt were
compounds come from particles,
also CIS also sea salt.
So eventually you put all of this and
this, and this is simulation obviously,
but you can see that
the in the atmosphere,
the way this article
Travis or of the worries,
very amazing right away we started out.
So most of,
most of us we know about climate change.
That's another, it's, it's a dumb thing.
It doesn't matter.
So all we all know that temperature will
increase by the end of the 21st century.
But the dependence on the way we
will meet if we are made to more,
more signature les Sia too.
If we change land uses are not
in many things but, but anyway,
even if we reduce everything,
even if we are stalled,
temperature is going to increase.
Right?
But the problem is that how
much that's the key west.
So we have different scenarios and
the Democrats are down in the old,
more optimistic.
In the most optimistic scenario,
temperature can increase made end of
the century zero point suite and in the
worst lung up to five.
Right. And why is that? Well,
Ferris because of the of the eight
scenarios, right. But second,
because there are many processes that
we don't know, we don't know well yet,
right?
If you see the error of ours.
So essentially the aerosol
particles I was telling you,
or club interaction,
I also radiation,
they come through with the highest
error taught anthropogenic forcing on
climate.
Right?
So what, what I eat, what to
work with my, with my phd's,
we should call April theses.
So the Cli, both SEZ solving,
it's not a policy is he's not this, not
solving that real [inaudible] are fucked.
And you will see that they all
the, the the, some, sorry, kids.
The, the, the surface of the ocean.
The ocean worlds, right. You see,
as the ocean warms,
their feet upon zone will grow because
leaving beans are happy when the
temperature east side, right?
Nope. Health much higher. Uh,
they were quite happy when they're,
when they're quite hubby,
they began to release
some of these trace gases,
almost these compounds like
vms, the mythical suicide,
right? These trace gases,
they go to the other moss
here, right? And they,
they react with soul for,
and they increased the concentration
of song compounds that eventually will
become particles,
right?
We help to create clouds.
So essentially it's like the microorganism
are able to react to the warm up the
waters on create like an umbrella for
them, right? This is not something,
I mean, let's say true because obviously
Mike Organism, they kind of think, right?
They don't do that in purpose. But
essentially this is a reaction we task.
We can go here in many places and
Angelie like everything is science.
Things are Moscow employee things are
much more complex than that, right?
So we have these trace gases.
We tire since elite Guy,
she is produced by the
biological ecosystem.
We targeted organism leaving
in the surface. Right?
But also we have other kind of
aerosols like when the, when the waves,
for example, date when they break, right?
They released some Cecil articles
that go to the atmosphere too.
So it's such a complex thing,
right? And this is the thing,
at least contributing more to the
Eh, to the answer. Dainty leveling,
climate change projections
for this century.
So this is on a Ieg,
all of representation of the south
and ocean and the Arctic Ocean, right?
So you can see there being ways you're
going to see seals can see the famous
creel over there, right?
You see the career.
So what I do for a Btb,
these partner,
obviously the sizes are not the real,
right? So this is like a micro organism.
This organism can be one
millimeter, right? So this is not,
it's not real that you can see there.
These are postop,
this purple stuff going from
the ocean into the atmosphere.
These are trace gases
that where we started the,
eventually they become articles and they
will help in clubs, formation processes,
but also,
but also they are like eh,
signals for some animals like seagulls.
So when a seagull is flying right,
they don't see what he's below the water.
Obviously there,
if there is something like an oil lacy,
but if they want to break Krill, they
usually see the critical and their flight,
but they kind of Smelly,
right? So these trays,
Garcia or Natalia important because
they held in the cloud formation versus,
but also they're important
chemical signals for animals.
If we think in the ocean, we all
have seen documentaries, right?
And we usually tend to think that the
ocean is something we taste and full Wales
Delphine's, um, being this dumpy,
but actually the old Chinese,
it's mostly empty. All of
these big animals, right?
The mostly for my bacteria by microbes.
So they all kind of St Helia
microbial soup. Um, the visit,
the number over kills bacteria and the
ocean, which is one all by 13 zero s
yeah.
Um, I was telling you about the gassy.
So these are the trace gas has to,
for my phd, which is called ISO bring.
And he says [inaudible] trace gas,
which is produced inside every cell
on the earth doing photosynthesis.
Every sale on the earth.
The task plastics. Right,
which are the Oregon's where
we're focusing is produced. Right.
But these mostly produced by,
by land and by lung plans,
router down Fido Bunco we teach that we
charged a microbial organism leaving in
the ocean that are able to
do for the census is right.
You may think why is important.
Well it goes to the lifetime in the
atmosphere of these trace gases.
So east really low, really low. Um,
so they have lost enough time to travel
from one continent to another word like
this, a higher on dust, right?
So lifetime lifetime
from two to three hours.
So when I saw is releasing the ocean,
it reacts immediately in this area
or in a really close area, right?
So the clouds that are formed there,
they came from these,
they are produced by these trace gases.
That's the importance of Elvis studying
these trace gases in the ocean.
And also because the
ones that are in meat in,
in England, they are interacting
with some anthropogenic.
Yes, he's on par. Two goals
for an industry. Um, these
are these kind of things.
So these are some of the organisms
living in the, in the surface ocean,
and they do the photosynthesis
on day release. These compounds,
the the dope, right of the big, you can
see progress locos broker, Coco's Isa,
back to your plant them,
which is how bacteria is able
to perform photosynthesis,
right on these organisms. It was
discovered by the MIT in the early India,
late eighties in early
19 so when I was born,
this organism didn't even exist. He just
seeks whether we didn't know, right?
So this is the most abundant organisms
on earth and this is the most abundant
organisms able to do the photosynthesis.
And actually I've already into some
estimates from the 20% or from the,
you can say 15% 25% of the seeking.
We are briefing here.
It has been produced by disorganizing
and 28 years ago, 27 years say, well,
we didn't even know that
these organismic seasons.
So the ocean is salt in that there are,
we have many things to this
core steel. Well, what I do,
so I use my deposit down models,
physical models.
This is a model for an
ETA for my collaborators.
And here you can see the ocean currents,
how they change during
the on every season.
Did you kind of see that some
parts are dark, dark, sorry,
which means that the speed is pretty high,
right?
So you can see that the itself and often
it's in the south and ocean, right?
I mean it's not something like like
a Tom see something really cold.
This is like the tasks like
rivers flowing inside, right?
So this is the biology.
So this is the way these micro
organism called phytoplankton,
they're able to do photosynthesis
change through the year.
You can see it's brain
arrives and they blew,
they booming build.
So the mission of these trace
gases in the seasons is higher
of what else? So we have, we have these
smaller, which is like a physical model,
right?
But we also need to know how
the marine ecosystem works,
right?
So we have the w that's like alarm.
So you have the primary production
errors you have to consumers.
You have the predates hours, right? So,
so do you have nutrient you need to know,
which is the amount of nutrients they
have in we in the south and ocean for
example.
How many species are producers?
You want Tom in his pieces
are per day tours. You will.
So this is the here, it looks really
simple that eventually this is a,
this is a really big branch of
regulations including one mall.
What we do here,
what I'm doing here for my phd is yes,
putting off this to wherever.
So we have the physical framework with
the car runs and production or whatever.
So we have like assist
cause he's taking a diagram.
Let's say we know how the ecosystem,
how the microbial ecosystem
works in the south and ocean.
And we also know which amount of these
trace gases are MEP by every cell.
And eventually we put all of these Twitter
so we can estimate for a couple day
meeting a Pfizer bring in
the whole south and ocean,
right?
Well this is the Muslim part. This is
the, let's say the mathematical part,
but we need data and if we need data,
we need to travel really far and we
need to do all Shannon, graphic cruises,
oceanographic institutions.
So these are the views from my,
from my Kevin I to be living inside
here like two months discouraged in the
English Channel when we were sailing
for a long course or in Germany to South
Africa. So the first career
that at the first cruise,
how you participate in order to measure
these compounds and see how the,
how they are releasing the ocean was
these ones are as big as 20 2014.
We are starting to spin and
we arrive to South America,
these salient the Atlantic Ocean Marcy,
if ways you have to be there like working,
everyone gets the sea to everyone gets DC.
I mean some people say you know,
I know everyone at some point gets dizzy
but what if you want to go to the
south and altering? So this is south,
I'm very candid and Arctic peninsula,
you can see this,
this here, that's there. We'll see. Um,
so if you want to reach this
self an ocean, you need to
cross the Drake passage,
right? The Drake passage is the most
dangerous place in the world for sale.
I don't know if you like salient,
but if you see this bold races that
every year when they have to grow through
there is a total mess for us.
It's easier because our bolts are bigger.
They are not, they are investors.
There are not both there,
they are not sailing boats at all.
So it's very easy.
Now the point is that you have a
belt of storms coming every field,
every three days,
and the time that the storms is
there is three days to under time.
Do you have to spend in order to go from
South America to Antartica three days
to an hour rate.
So the point is that you have to be
there waiting and there was term going.
That's the moment you start with the boat
trying to reach Antarctica before and
he has term we'd arrive, right?
It's a very difficult place to be.
So we performed these screens,
which is called Picasso. Um,
we went to these areas, health and
all. So that's South America. Um,
that they need to laugh.
We have a been wing,
which was really happy with us
and he jumped into the Cilia. Um,
so we went with this research vessel
here you have the proof that this is
sure
there look at a deficit for real.
I don't know.
So they're usually,
depending on the place you
go on Antarctica and usually
animals are not really
used to human means, right?
So they don't respect you.
So even a being we teach like
it's like a feature of their,
it's like a seagull is like
one of the ease of the,
he's an animal that is prey by
most of the rest of the others.
They don't even care about
you jump there on their board,
they jump up.
This is how it looks when you are crossing
the Drake passage from South America
too on [inaudible] gun.
These are the people we were there working
to better sell how we weren't there.
So we sample it many different ways.
So this one is for something they micro
layers and the micro surface layer of
the ocean.
So essentially we introduce one plate
of glass and then must surface layer of
the ocean get stuck on it. And
after we cleaned like this, uh, we,
we,
we get these syrups in this order.
In order to feel this bottle,
we need to spend like one hour there.
So this is [inaudible],
right?
So we have small boats inside the big
bolt that we use sampling over there said
you're going to see in the
background, uh, an ice layer.
We also use these, these sermon,
which is called Rosette CTD. Russell.
This is the most iconic
instrumenting ocean sciences, right?
So you can see there, it looks like, um,
well essentially you have all
of these are bottles, right?
And every bottle has an amber.
So Judy ploy this instrument and you
deploy it until the border for the seat or
until the, that you want, right? When
it's going down, it's measuring, right?
But it's going now, especially Sanford,
her measures for inventory to her.
So let me did measure that so you
can see how it looks, the ocean,
how it will,
how is the vertical profiles or of
their main properties of the ocean,
let's say.
And when you recover it and he's going,
you can tell from the boat
to every bottle. So open up,
open up distance,
you can tell the bottom number six.
So you will be open to their port,
400 meters.
So under the bottle number,
five to 100 meters, whatever.
When you got it back on the boat and
you put it here that you have different
models and every Volvo has the water,
a different debt.
She says mark way of sampling rather
than going with a submarine or are these
kind of things we start
which are really expensive.
So that's the way we usually pick the
water from the depot. We don't go,
it's so marines or,
or we don't dive there.
So we use these kind of instrument
which has been used in during the last
decades.
We also perform experiments or more.
So these containers,
they're,
they have water pumping
from the and directly. Um,
so in order to keep the same temperature
in the ocean done in these boxes let's
say,
and there we have small borders,
we've committed different fighter on
communities there we see how they react
with the, with, with the
light or in our conditions.
This that with all day?
Both as is you on a test.
We also big eyes. That's
me. Begin some eyes.
And why we big eyes with an axe.
Because I mean you can see here in this
picture, this is not fear the ice, right?
So you could go see inside the eyes.
They're leaving beans too.
So you start the ice. We
have phytoplankton too and
they live there, right?
So on this such an important
thing because actually
Kareel usually eat these federal bundle.
They go below the ice and this carotid.
So these are, it's almost the organism
done the we found inside the eyes.
So to make sure at least
full of leaving means,
okay,
do we participate also in the ace Murray
Team University, which was a universe,
a cruise.
What started him Bremerhaven
Germany onto the South Africa.
That was a cruise that we
were scientists working there,
but also 50th students
from all over the world.
We sold many things like flying few,
she's,
I don't know if you have ever seen them.
And we were on the academics
first Nichols research vessel.
And this project was funded by the Swiss
polar incidents, which is around by you,
this fiscal Roman Ada, t VFL, um,
older institutions for [inaudible].
So this is how our lab look like,
right?
We were setting up the lobby,
not moment.
You can see there the [inaudible] the,
and I told you it's quite claustrophobic.
Everything, right? So,
okay.
Pretty smile. Pretty small, no windows
he sees around him. The
Baltimore Sun, the cables,
all used to be the finest thing is you are
on a basal, so everything moves, right?
So do you have to tie everything to
the walls? Even the chairs are there.
They're tied to the floor, right?
So everything kind of be, I mean,
everything has to be really stable because
if you have a festo literally chairs
for example,
they come eat will love them.
The MV flying over the rooms.
Okay.
So on last year we participate the,
well, two years ago must be right.
That's you're actually [inaudible]
Felicia as well. So cruises,
starting from Africa. Um, but, uh,
after we went to Hobart in Australia,
[inaudible],
rns in South America and Africa again,
so it was that whole street navigation
of Antarctica. What's was the first time,
uh, an international expedition has
done it all history by Internet.
We found scientific age, right?
Um, so Liesel fly a squeeze.
I don't know if you,
if you knew that we'd have flying fishes
on the ocean was also playing a squids.
I have to recognize that I
have even know eat until,
until that moment that they exist.
Um,
so we sold many keeping
[inaudible] Kim being green,
which is the second biggest one
after the ember of being me. Um, yes.
[inaudible] he's coming in.
We are interested.
So the expedition was divided
in three different legs,
on every leg was more or less one month,
right on a park.
You see facing the first one.
Okay.
I said,
these are some pictures.
This is camping with this is
many of them do better having
baby big means on everything.
So they,
I saw Davis Hill,
how one of them was killed
by these school us. Um, um,
or over seagulls,
partner's health and ocean.
So this is [inaudible] speaking.
It's like real like otherwise.
Okay.
Um,
this one will be able through some of the,
when we were starting from Cape Town
oldest,
so we were there.
So you can see that the usually east
really cloudy and the weather is good.
So if you see documentaries
with being weaned on the song,
that's not the normal thing.
They're usually really,
that's how we work. So in the same
place, we have to have, we have plans,
we have the here, so we have the
meetings because I usually do,
they'll hop so many saloons on level.
So this space is really sweetie pie.
You said all of these old, the kinds
of things we were doing this course.
So these people,
they were launching balloons and
Isabelle Lewis are used to measure the
properties of the atmosphere.
For example,
deploying many different instruments.
Okay.
What is this? So when I show this
picture to high schools to this,
they told me what this is.
I Dunno.
Is Saturn or Jupiter or our planet?
So this is the Pacific Ocean.
So if you, if you use, obviously you
do because you do use Google earth,
did you slept? I mean if you do a little
bit be a buck, so you will find these,
the Pacific Ocean is massive.
Something that big that you
can pull all the continents,
all the land inside the Pacific Ocean.
And after that you will have,
you will leave a little
bit of Pacific Ocean.
The Pacific Ocean is really big and
as you can see there are clouds there.
So what we have done this year,
we went to these points in the
middle of the Pacific Ocean,
which is Maria Island
in the French Polynesia.
I don't know if you know where you start
heating so close with the heat either.
It's Maria.
I love.
So we were there in order to study
these trace gases emission on by Murray.
Microsoft's,
uh,
that was all the worry microbes
that are also from Colorado.
Reese is coral reef.
They have differing in coral reef
ecosystems or they can't have different
behavior or sunny spot and touristy.
So you have until the s I told you
in the beginning. So you need to,
you need to understand
the ocean as a possible.
So you need to know how all of these is.
These are in every part of the ocean.
So that's Maria Island.
And we
were there, he said the
island, it's pretty cool.
So we were leaving here on
these houses on the one day,
but it was really beautiful at night.
And this is unreal.
I mean usually these kind of,
I mean when you came from the south and
ocean and you are right to the tropic
tropical island,
like this is really funny because he's
like living in an aquarium and you every
time you die, if it's like you cannot
believe what you are saying because he's,
it's like fake,
but it's not fake.
It's full of chorus and everything.
So this is the research team.
We were there. We were yesterday
team people from four different,
if it were for four different countries
for new year over in the states,
from China, from Australia,
from, uh, Spain. Um,
from friends too.
Okay.
This is the boat we use on that cruise.
That of course we'll either,
they pull us in our careers,
we were working from a night
on the right. So every,
every day we do them all
down. We went sampling. And
this is the day, for example,
in this picture, what we are doing
is deploying this rally your meter,
which is an instrument that you can
use for measure. How, how, how's the,
how, what is the, I mean, who,
how are the properties of the
light and below the surface water.
So how lights be gay with the Dev,
for example,
which is an indicator of the
turbidity and these kind of things.
And that's me working on the
boat. So you have to, uh, the,
he's the driver of the boat.
Tony and I used to spend many hours
close to his feet working there.
We follow the coating.
So essentially it's like you have like
really fancy instrument and really
expensive things, but mentally
you are, you know, you need to do,
you need to adapt to the
circumstances. Um, so we,
uh, we were doing, I mean, when we went
with the bolt sampling, for example,
in Maria Aiello pictures from the right,
so when we saw how this is the day
in green, you have the chlorophyll,
which is an indicator of the
productivity of a community or,
or the water,
like say let's say.
So we saw that in the basic productivity
was higher than out of the reef and
inside the roof.
So that's the thing we usually do.
And we went to this small atolls in
the, in the north, which is [inaudible].
And here you have the bigger picture.
Um,
so an angel is the, it's not, I mean
this angel, it was really different.
And I'm Maria, right? Um,
it has inside that legroom and on the
productivity there was really high.
It was much higher than out
of the whole of the island,
which was something
really surprising for us.
So the last thing I would
like to tell you, it's about
science and society, right?
So these kind of things are
very important. And you also,
you have to explain them to the people.
You have to explain it to society.
So this is model, it's not
a spin expedition, right?
Was an expedition performing an
18th century. Like by, by his thing,
it was the first IMT if
[inaudible] the award sampling,
leaving curators for an island.
So many different things.
So in 2010 so eight years ago,
there was a Malaspina expedition, which
was a cruise sailing around the ocean,
right? Again, buzz, I spill Roman,
you see some feel really cool.
So you have a massive bold full of
scientists traveling around the world.
In seven months. We see something
that you may think, well,
this is so easy to reach.
So easy to engage with the
people on the pneumonia.
I was on my bachelor and I used to
read the blog and this wasn't as block.
So it's that. So here you
have, I mean, you don't have
to read it, but no pictures,
no movies,
no nothing.
So do you have people sailing around
the globe doing really cool science?
You percentage like this?
Um, I'm actually this, this,
this is how this one,
the,
the offer of this writing is
one of the most famous is fine.
It's Fraser says you will have on the
boat one of the best writers on the ward
and you are doing really cool things
and you present it like this with no
parochial media though. No Twitter, no
Facebook, no nothing. So he mentally,
no one will really few people.
It's going to read this
unless you're a freak like me,
but if you want to engage, but if
you want to engage with these people,
millennials. Huh? Well I did
relation on the two younger ones.
So you need to use social media.
Um,
I agree with mine with my partner at
spoke in September, 2014, you know,
are very good splay. They
said these eh, um, to,
to explain and to read. But you
expedition, as I told you before,
it will seem both
focusing on storytelling,
adventure of the challenges of science on,
do you athlete from assign
these to the public or ma,
I'm mostly focusing in John People.
So we have read them most in all of
these different places on their war,
which he's quite and
quite cool in 40 years.
This is what I wanted to tell you.
Thank you. And if you have any question,
we'll be happy to answer.
And those results,
did you get from all these experiments?
Every on every ocean is different
on every experiments different.
So the results we have with the
Easter, depending, for example,
depending on the photo blogs and Spc.
So because you may think,
well if these tourists gas is related
to chlorophyll, so chlorophyll molecule,
which is the same, the water of the
organism, the molecule is the same.
So do you may think so maybe can we
kind of link the productions of discuss?
Yes. To glorify him, but
actually it doesn't work
that, so depending on this PC,
even no matter of the chlorophyll of
the level of chlorophyll of this PC,
so the mission can be different
if the two basic gases.
But what does the response team were fun.
Yeah.
I have a question from one of the
people who is not in this room. Um,
yeah,
he's thinking more towards
the global warming those.
So he says that every time our,
our CEO and our higher ups
talk about machine learning,
he talks about the example of climate
change modeling and he's asking if you're
aware of machine learning
initiatives to improve these models.
But it seems like climb on modeling
within 150 years of data is still a good
candidate for applying machine learning
to such, uh, such research. So what,
what's kind of your viewer experience?
Well, tell you what would I do
with the models I use. I mean,
I'm not that modal little over and
then we'll usually usually, right.
So actually my intention with this
mall's either he's not, I mean the,
the final goal of this obviously is to
help the people do project the climate.
My Jaquelle goals, right? Uh,
I am a word and now they're using these,
these machine learning things
for incubation community,
bloody of the malls and also
quantum quantum computing to,
so yes, I'm thinking something that is
a hot topic now. It's currently, I mean,
that's what my goals, but I'm not
that, I have no extra pieces of that.
Yeah.
That's all because really enjoyable.
Um,
I'm wondering on your whole research team,
how many people go out into the field
and gather the data and how many people
stay home and write code and run models.
And how's the interaction between you?
Because I'm considering,
well, it depends on the cruise, right?
For example, in one of the crews,
the one that we did in these,
in these oceanographic vessel like this,
we, that's the Spanish basal. So
we have like 35 births for us,
so that we were like 30 scientists to,
were working still.
Did people love do millennia stuff? He's
come face, usually they stay on them,
but some nice not right. Um, so
for example, in these groups,
we were 30 scientists in the cruise
that we did around on 30 guy from my
research group. We, yes. Got
Two places. So we were just too,
it's funny is people there and we were,
you know, [inaudible] tiller every month.
Um, so it depends on the groups and
on the island. The smallest of April,
we were 13 people.
So yeah,
he depends on the also it
depends obviously the, the,
the more people you have
the better because you can
do more things and you kind
of have more data about this.
Skanska Lee is something that you need to,
I mean it's a kind of science that
is quite complex because isn't it?
Clearly you have to take your lab.
I'm more with,
I feel that we take our lab and we put
it inside the boat and the boat is never
in Barcelona.
So we have to go to Germany or to
whatever and you need to take all of our
instruments there.
We put in a boat and sales around the
world and after you became out of, um,
so he's, that's a complex thing. But I
want to say that that's expensive too.
So the more people, the better, the more
people, the more expressive abilities.
So the St Kelly, do you need to
think? I need to, you need to have,
clearly you're and I will, what I have,
what I want to do to these people.
You're not,
so usually try to keep the number
of people a slower as possible,
um,
that will help you to have your,
your scientific goals.
Yeah.
So you mentioned, uh, different types
of photosynthesis has different,
uh,
to affect like the amount of pipe and
Joseph mission by net amount of bacteria,
or at least
it's mostly because of the animals of
the animals off the plant. Right. So,
so the bigger is
going to be producing it,
so there'd be your east always needed
more than what we produce is the same way
if you read, do our release in Morsia
too than, um, than a mouse problem.
So it's something similar to that.
So you have more biomass,
all that Mark Morford doesn't getting
higher biomass on land. I mean the old,
but the point is that their
bio mass in the ocean, so
it becomes recycled faster,
you know, because they're
essentially microbes. Right.
And they die, but they, they can be by the
cells. You have to offend. You have free.
So the bio mass is lower than
in Donny land past. Yeah.
That's reasonable.
Not One I had. No, I did.
Uh, did I include the side?
Okay. Okay. Ah, yeah. That's
my, that's my, that's my two,
three theater user if you mean.
Oh yeah.
Okay.
Well is the same.
Yeah.
So you said that,
but he's the plans to release more as
a friend because they are important.
Why is it not the same with oxygen?
You said that to the oxygen is
mostly released by these microbes.
Well because that's how you're really
good as good as him because I actually did
a, we usually land ecosystems,
right? They love steak.
The plus data for the,
but they also, they bring,
let's say they also consume
oxygen sometimes, right?
So when you have an ecosystem which is
mature, right? Like the rain forest,
they're producing data. They are
producing a little of folks senior about,
they're consuming a lot of
oxygen to cells. Hailey, you're,
your balance is lady some,
some parts of the London
ecosystem is zero.
So I think the older and these organisms
are dying and leaving the gang.
I'm the level. So he's play
is that's heavy for the thing.
Yeah.
I sailed through a tall ship through
the Drake's passage half a year ago and
yeah, it was really bad. Um, I wanted
to comment on, on your common desk.
Um,
like research vessels,
like the one that I was on,
we could use money for like keeping
the business after running a day.
Also collect samples.
Uh,
like we used to measure part of our
daily chores was to measure the water
temperature and sometimes
the examples and um,
okay,
these data,
is he 42 some other agencies?
I don't remember exactly where in
exchange for a small amount of money in my
understanding was that this
kind of research feeds, uh,
is kind of small samples.
Data feeds into like larger research at
a global level and there are other boats
like this that you can volunteer
on or you can just join them for,
I don't know,
five weeks from Cape Town to the Azores.
Or I went from [inaudible]
to Ben Antarctic Peninsula
and back in those 22 days
or the same, uh, shy
Antarctic pennies. Ah, AH,
Georgian islands in Cape Town.
And we collected the sword of samples
every eight hours come whatever kind of
weather and dizziness and so on.
So I think there's maybe opportunity if
you're interested to look into what kind
of research these data ends up being
used for and if there's some sort of more
intelligent machine learning
and things that we could,
or one could contribute
if there's interest.
Okay.
Have some sort of website like
that and probably that was, yeah,
yeah.
Uh, Evan to lead, you can join us on a
research cruise, but actually in order to,
that was healthy that the has been doing
like during the last day. It's like,
yeah, yes. Launching those hills and
people doing, they're measuring enough,
they're sharing everything
and put everything together.
Now this trend is seen of these
quite trendy is the Argo float.
I don't know if you have deliver
ever listen about Argo floats.
So essentially there are
boys, right? Like these ones,
can you help me low? Can you
go there you go, hold on.
And they seem to not have two satellites
on there. So they are perfect.
They're not simply floating there.
Go with deeper Nicola afterwards.
So on the, so the Argo flower,
the Argo floats, sorry,
are all the argue boys
that are in the ocean,
which is this in February, 2018. Right?
So the ocean as many of
these are the flows. Um,
usually they own most of them.
I mean,
almost every gun three they have a group
in charge of deploying the Argo floats.
Do do is change the Chantilly,
deploy them on when they uh,
run off battery elder butter.
He said you've picked them up and you
do repairs and you launch it again,
which is so thing,
which is cheaper than send
people is safer to me girls,
if our boy becomes broken,
no one's eyes.
Yeah.
Okay.
So,
uh,
it says you are studying what looks
like a positive feedback loops towards
global warming. Any chances it can
offset the major negative feedback loops?
Like I'll be the loss from ice melting.
COC decreasing Sio two storage,
permafrost, melting
releases, ch four and so on.
Yeah.
What is that with climate change?
And usually because, I mean we, we,
we usually tends to understand
climate change as global warming.
Exactly it is now is global warming.
But if you have a really high global
warming, do you even count, you know,
gloves she'll glacial period.
Right. So something quite tricky.
For example, if, if all of the,
for example that he or
he was saying if the,
if the ice melts in
the Arctic for example,
so the temperature of the ocean
will be higher on a, I don't really,
if you are a word,
the heating machine of the earth are,
the oceans are saying Kelly,
you half a convention belt
hole throw the oceans,
which is called a terrible
Holly circulation. Um,
east a saint.
Really it's like a river.
You just slowly for a one place to
another one transporting eat, right.
So if they'll sharing, for
example, if the Arctic,
I mean we are in Switzerland, I
don't know if you, well you know,
Love Madrid for example,
because the lesson it is more or less
in the same latitude than New York,
but the temperature is totally different.
You, your patent, you have seen movies,
bright eyes response,
every face full of snow.
And usually in Spain we don't
have that. Or, or in Lisbon,
which is largely to that is because in
the North Atlantic Ocean we have this
commercial belt of, of water,
which is called the Emoc,
a mock Lutie, Stearns, Arctic, very
regional overturning circulation.
So then we're warm waters that are,
that they have, they have,
I mean they, the, they have,
they are warm because the,
the signing day waiter gets the water
that the water flows north of low self do
as health an ocean to the
article in the Atlantic Ocean,
right when they arrive to
the North Pole or the Arctic,
they get to cool David colder.
Right? And if they are cooler,
they go down,
right?
So they go down after they are
doing their way back but below.
Right.
And this has had an atmos very clean too.
So essentially we have
this warm temperatures in,
in Europe rather than in America because
of this, because of the circulation.
But if the Arctic is warmer, the
CFTC stipulation, the mock can be,
can be broken or can be, um, or, or your,
or even if that's
regulation is just lower.
It kind of really changed
the whole of Europe.
And it will be colder.
So mentally,
if you do have a lot of a lot of flow
where you can have a glass show and not a
glacial period,
or maybe a glacial period,
but much lower 10 producing
places of you have never had,
well,
we have never had in the last selenium's.
Yeah.
Such a drinking game.
Thanks.
See you.